mes chers amis au moment où nous allons
élire le nouveau président du conseil
national je voudrais à mon tour
remercier celui qui pendant des années à
travailler à l'unité de notre mouvement
a su animer ce conseil avec le talent
avec la finesse avec un brin de malice
je dois dire et beaucoup d'empathie
j'ai cité jean pierre raffarin je crois
qu'il mérite une nouvelle salve
d'applaudissements alors pour la
première fois vous allez élire votre
président du conseil national
c'est une belle avancée démocratique
cette avancée nous l'avons nous la
devons à nos nouveaux statuts
voulu par nicolas sarkozy statut que
vous avez approuvé ces statuts nous ont
permis de rapprocher le pouvoir de
décision des militants vous avez élu
récemment directement au suffrage direct
au président de fédé et c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui
à 27 ans dans la fédération des alpes de
haute provence
sébastien giné est devenu le plus jeune
président de fédération des républicains
et il mérite vos applaudissements
c'est ce qui fait qu en indre et loire
inès chabbiha moins de 20 ans est
aujourd'hui la benjamine de ce conseil
national elle mérite vos encouragements
grâce à ces nouveaux statuts
nous avons pour la première fois au
bureau politique à la commission
exécutive la parité hommes femmes
bref mes chers amis nous montrons
aujourd'hui le visage d'un parti moderne
un parti qui débat un parti qui respire
et ça c'est déjà une prend
la victoire alors en arrivant ce matin
je vais vous dire je me remémorais mon
premier conseil national
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'avais
travaillé pendant la semaine dans mon
entreprise vous avez que je viens de
l'entreprise je m'étais levé tôt le
matin la seule différence c'est que à
l'époque mon cher daniel ont remboursé
les frais de déplacement si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
je m'étais j'ai installé au fond de la
salle et j'étais fier de faire partie
des cadres de notre parti
j'étais fier d'avoir été élu au
parlement du parti
et si je suis candidat aujourd'hui à la
présidence du conseil national c'est
d'abord parce que j'en connais tous les
échelons que j'ai franchi étape par
étape conseiller national s des délégués
de circo aujourd'hui président de
fédération et cette progression mes
chers amis je ne la doit qu'à une seule
chose le travail de terrain savez moi je
n'ai jamais été parachuté je ne suis pas
un héritier je dois mon travail mais mon
action mais résultats au travail de
terrain
eh bien je pense que c'est important que
le président de notre conseil national
incarne cette méritocratie militante
cher à nos valeurs comme comme beaucoup
d'entre vous je suis d'abord un disciple
du rassemblement vous savez que
j'appartiens avec valérie avec nathalie
avec xavier avec eric à la génération
élus à l'assemblée nationale en 2002
après la création de l'ump voulue par
jacques chirac
eh bien j'ai toujours privilégié
l'intérêt collectif
souvenez-vous en 2014 lorsque notre
parti a traversé une crise si grave
je suis devenu votre secrétaire générale
sous la présidence d'alain juppé de
françois fillon et de jean-pierre
raffarin
notre parti était au bord de
l'éclatement
il menaçait de sombrer de disparaître je
dois dire qu'à l'époque il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de candidats pour être
secrétaire général et bien pendant ses
cent cinquante jours de période de
transition
j'ai toujours cherché la voie de
l'apaisement la voie du rassemblement et
je me suis d'abord appuyé sur vous
les cadres du mouvement et c'est vous
qui avez tenu c'est vous qui vouliez
l'unité du parti
ensemble nous avons panser les plaies
nous avons redressé la tête et il faut
le dire nous avons sauvé le parti je
suis fier d'avoir engagé le redressement
financier de notre famille travaillent
aujourd'hui amplifiée par daniel
fasquelle
il ne fallait pas flanché vous savez
pouvez l'applaudir
il y en a besoin pour aller rechercher
les cotisations des lui il faut pas
flancher
nous pouvons être fiers ensemble d'avoir
été le premier parti politique à
organiser un vote électronique à grande
échelle une élection incontestable à la
présidence du mouvement qui a permis
après un beau débat avec bruno le maire
avec hervé mariton l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy
voilà pourquoi je suis candidat
aujourd'hui je veux présider ce conseil
national dans le même esprit
d'apaisement d'unité et de rassemblement
qui m'a guidé lorsque j'étais le
secrétaire général et je crains que dans
les mois qui viennent nous ayons un peu
besoin de cet esprit d'unité
je crois que dans les mois qui viennent
ce ne sera pas une exigence
ce sera la condition de la victoire
voilà pourquoi je leur dis sans aucune
ambiguïté je ne serai pas candidat à la
primaire je considère que le président
du conseil national parce qu'il est le
garant de l'unité du parti ne doit pas
être candidat à la primaire
alors on dit que vous n'êtes que nous
sommes le parlement du parti
très bien eh bien faisons ensemble un
parlement du 21e siècle
changeons d'époque ensemble un parti
moderne ce n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement
c'est pas une salle où on fait la claque
aux dirigeants un parti moderne c'est
pas un conseil avec des votes bloqués
c'est pas une caserne un parti moderne
c'est pas un parti qui décide à paris et
des conseillers nationaux dans les faits
dès qu'ils exécutent
ça c'est fini on ne veut plus non un
parti moderne c'est un parlement où la
démocratie est à tous les étages
le conseil national il doit être la
caisse de résonance de nos territoires
de nos fédé et doit exprimer la vitalité
de nos forces vives de ce qui maillent
le territoire de ceux qui triment sur le
terrain le porte parole de ce qu'on peut
jamais entendre et bien pour faire de ce
conseil national le parlement d'un parti
du 21e siècle
je voudrais pour terminer vous faire
trois propositions rapides
d'abord un parlement aura un parlement
moderne ça serait une eee pad
une fois deux fois par an oui je me
tourne vers les nouveaux vous a
peut-être pas prévenu mes deux fois
c'est plutôt les années bissextiles
bon eh bien écoutez à l'heure d'internet
à l'heure des nouvelles technologies
un parti moderne ça travaille en réseau
nous pouvons monter un réseau de tous
les conseillers nationaux qui des vagues
qui échange qui parlent de leur
expérience de terrain et ça on n'a pas
besoin de la direction du mouvement pour
demander l'autorisation
deuxièmement je les dis vous êtes
nombreux à redouter la période qui va
s'ouvrir la primaire vous avez vos
préférences
chacun a ses amitiés dans la salle l'un
des stars qu il ya des jupes et il ya
des fillon il ya des le maire y aller
mariton je vais m'arrêter là parce que
j'avais des problèmes mais en bref vous
avez vos préférences tant mieux tant
mieux mais à la fin c'est les
républicains qui doivent gagner nous
devrons nous rassembler
enfin le conseil national doit peser
davantage sur la direction du mouvement
mon cher nicolas
si je suis élu président du conseil
national dès lundi j'installerai un
bureau de notre conseil national de 40
membres à parité qui avant chaque
réunion du parti bureau politique
conseil national congrès pourra débattre
des sujets à l'ordre du jour pourra
faire vivre le mouvement
voilà mes chers amis pourquoi je suis
candidat pour terminer je voudrais vous
donner une dernière raison je suis
candidat finalement pour les mêmes
raisons qui vous ont amené ce matin à ce
conseil national ces raisons qui font
que tous les jours des français
franchissent la porte de nos permanences
ces mêmes raisons qui poussent nos
militants à l'heure où je vous parle à
se dépenser sans compter sur les marchés
l'amour de la france la fierté de
défendre des idées
la conviction de servir son pays est
bien dans les mois qui viennent la
france aura besoin des républicains nous
allons avoir une responsabilité immense
nous n'avons pas le droit de décevoir
notre pays est aujourd'hui je termine
dans une tourmente qui ressemble
étrangement à celle décrite le 4
septembre 1958 par le général de gaulle
tandis qu'une immense vague de fond se
formait des profondeurs notre pays se
montrait incapable de s'adapter
monde nouveau c'est alors qu'au milieu
de la tourmente
apparu la république elle était la
souveraineté du peuple
l'appel de la liberté et bien mes chers
amis
cet appel de la liberté cet appel à la
souveraineté du peuple
nous devons l'incarner je vous demande
vous conseillers nationaux membres du
parlement de notre parti de l'incarner
vive les républicains vive la république
et vive la france
merci